[Applaudissements]
et moi comme et bats a noté mary basket
samedi c'est petit et ou alors pendant
que scott se prépare vous allez juste ou
faire un retourné de perruques vous
allez la garder jusqu'à la fin de
l'émission je joue vous retourner ou
fêtes d'antan où es tu allez-y alors
allez-y vous la mettez sous les clameurs
jupe est non dangereux frérot bassam a
alors cessé de ses lacets moi tu diras
que c'est de ma faute
alors attention attention autour de vous
je vous appelez mokobé je vais finir sur
ok mokobé bas autour des baux et danton
où es tu danton où es tu attendais pas
apa
[Applaudissements]
je suis amusé stéphane vous allez devoir
y aller par le conduire au sol et là je
voulais rester à la cité mon père m'a
dit il elle est là alors je voulais
rester
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]